[Music]
hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're gonna
be going over the birds opening which
starts out pawn to f4
now the birds opening is not one of the
most popular moves compared to you know
the king pollen of the queen pawn
opening but I feel that this can be to
your benefit is most players aren't too
familiar playing it correctly as white
or defending it correctly as black so I
wanted to take some time to make a video
on some of the common themes that you'll
see in the bird opening if you ever come
across it or if you decide to play it
yourself and want to really study up an
opening that a lot of a lot of other
players may not know very well
so we'll go ahead and get into it first
move is f4 now black has a lot of
different options we'll go over a few
and then we'll kind of go over the main
line obviously sometimes you'll see you
know move like 'if I've which is the
from this game it from here
you know you can kind of choose if you
want to go ahead and capture this piece
or you can just transition straight into
the Kings gambit so if you're familiar
with the Kings gambit you can go ahead
and play that line you know if someone's
never played against the birds opening
they're usually not gonna offer up this
game it but you know just to keep that
in mind the main line though and the
moves may vary very slightly here and
there but the main line starts off with
Knight to f6
and then whites going to develop his
knight to f3 and white has the idea of
controlling the dark squares a lot of
times with white white usually tries to
control the light squares a lot of times
you'll see from the very beginning that
the light square bishop for white is
very powerful and why usually tries to
control the light squares where in this
case as you'll see White's going to try
to control the dark squares which is a
little bit different so in this case our
dark square Bishop were most the time in
the mainline we're gonna fianchetto our
Bishop to the b2 Square and our dark
square bishop is going to be very
valuable to us so as you can see right
away we have two attackers on this efox
squared and we have our knight attacking
this d4 square so we're attacking and
defending the dark squares so from here
and again the move order can change just
a little bit the main line is for black
to continue to d5 and you may see the
knight and the pawn move reversed but
either way this is the main line you can
see here that black is trying to attack
now the light squares and so you're
gonna have this tension and battle
throughout the game and a bird's opening
of one side try to control one color and
one side trying to control the other and
then one side is going to have to
eventually just give and so we're going
to talk about how to build up your
attack and how to make sure that you are
on the winning side of that so from here
white normally continues with III and
this does a couple things one it opens
up the door for our Bishop to get out
I prefer moving our Bishop out this way
some people and the birds opening will
fianchetto their bishop to the g2 square
it's a little harder to keep your king
in safety so I like this
III move and it also builds along these
dark squares too as you can see we now
have two attackers and defenders on the
d4 square and two attackers in defenders
on the e5 square from here a lot of
times you'll see black develop to c5 and
then white has two different options
here the more common move is just to
bring the bishop to to e2 getting ready
to Castle kingside with white and also
developing and defending this night here
in case black wants to bring down this
bishop the knight will no longer be
pinned to the Queen
another thing you know it all depends on
the player a lot of times people will
bring their Bishop to b5 and check black
and a lot of times in a bird's opening
white likes to trade off his light
square Bishop so let's say black were to
play you know Bishop to d7 since the
dark squares are the main priority for
white in this game his light square
Bishop is not as valuable so a lot of
times he'll just go ahead and trade off
his light square Bishop knowing that
he's going to fianchetto in a dark
Bishop and that's gonna be on a long
diagonal attacking the dark squares so I
personally don't like to give up my
bishops early on in a game but you know
if you play the birds opening a lot and
you feel like your light square Bishop
isn't getting a lot of play then you may
want to go ahead and
exchange pieces early on and that way
you don't have to worry about it it's
all about feel and what you feel most
comfortable with but the most common
play is just bishop ii ii ii ii here and
then from here you'll normally see black
develop his his Knight to c6 and then
from here you obviously want to castle
just for king protection we for white
the f2 square is a very big weakness at
the beginning as is the f7 square for
black and since our pawn is not here our
king is pretty vulnerable so we want to
go ahead and put him in a safer place
from here you'll normally see black
strengthen his pawn chain and also allow
his bishop to develop so that he can
Castle kingside as well and get his King
a safety from here you don't see white
start to fianchetto his Bishop so pawn
to b3 and then from here blacks just
going to develop his Bishop and then
White's going through the pinch Ito has
bit up Bishop to b2 and as you can see
white has the idea of putting a lot of
pressure on these these dark squares in
the middle each of these squares has
three defenders and attackers on it so
White's trying to do everything it can
to control the center of the board here
on the dark squares and this e3 pawn a
lot of times people will make a mistake
and just immediately push up there
they're deep pawn to d4 that's going to
be a mistake
your e3 pawn is a is a big weakness and
at the time being you want to kind of
hold back this deep to pawn if for
instance black were to try to bring his
pawn to d4 if he were to capture you
know from here White has the option of
just bringing this piece up kind of
waiting to see where this deep hunt
wants to go and then if black does
decide to capture then white can
recapture here but you don't want to
immediately move this this piece up
let's say we were just to move this
piece up here and then when they capture
then you recapture and then you don't
have you kind of have this F pawn hang
in there and then you have kind of a
weakness here so just a few tidbits to
kind of look at when you are playing the
game we'll go back to this position here
with the bishop on b2 and then from here
you'll just normally see black Castle
kingside so from here both sides are
gonna have you know a great game
obviously Black's trying to control the
light squares here and White's trying to
control the dark squares here so these
are some of the common things you want
to look for in the game if you see
something you know fishy that you're
like hey wait a minute just go ahead and
take and analyze the position see what
the other side is trying to do and play
from there the birds opening is not very
common so you're probably going to see
some pretty uncommon moves so just play
around with it
try to get better hope you guys enjoyed
if you haven't subscribed to go ahead
and subscribe and I'll see you guys next
video thanks for watching